welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and we just got a new behind the
scenes promo for Ant-Man and the wasps
quantumania that gives us some new
interesting moments from the film and
some really unusual VFX details and I'm
still trying to wrap my head around I
mean I don't feel too bad I'm probably
still gonna be trying to wrap my head
around the visuals for weeks after
seeing this movie but let's break down
the new visual details that you might
have missed quantumania is coming
February 17th and on that same day will
be the launch of our new channel the
Deep dive and a special announcement
right here right now over on the Deep
dive on that day I will be live
streaming to do a live breakdown of
quantumania that Friday morning giving
you a rare look under the hood at my
process where we can chat in real time
and you can see how I assemble my Easter
egg breakdowns and then that finished
product the Polish Easter egg breakdown
where Amanda was swanomania you will be
able to watch over here on new rock
stars that same day so please subscribe
at Deep dive in RN tune in on February
17th okay let's take a look at this
promo titled enter the quantum realm
Batman is arguably the character that is
the most underestimated Ant-Man became
the key to saving the universe verse in
Avengers end game so carrying that
tradition we thought well let's use this
film to kick off phase five Kevin feige
is Right Scott was the key to the Time
Heist using the quantum realm time
vortex's two-time travel and Scots lost
five years from Avengers end game will
be a crucial wedge point that Kang is
gonna exploit in this movie but you know
Hey Kevin give some credit where
credit's due it was really the storage
locker rat who crawled across that
control panel in the van that really
saved the universe was that rat said by
Kang the next shot shows Paul Rudd and
Catherine Newton on set the location of
the quantum realm where Scott and Cassie
first land and you can see that that
wasn't a green screen set but rather the
volume that we have seen in Productions
like Mandalorian so these actors
thankfully for them will have all had
something to look at and react to in
these scenes then we get another Quick
Clip I still kind of can't believe that
I'm sitting there and it's like wow
there's Michelle Pfeiffer and there's
Michael Douglas I just saved eight bucks
God I admire you ah so Hank Pym uses an
old school version of the pen particles
from the silver syringe to enlarge a
pizza for them to eat sorry but that's
still not enough for four people this
reminds me of the scene of Back to the
Future Part Two when they demonstrate
the advancements of future technology in
the home by showing the family inflating
the pizza oh boy oh boy mom you sure can
hydrate a pizza which now is especially
ironic considering how Scott an end game
compared their time travel logic to Back
to the Future and the whole second act
of that movie was really a love letter
to Back to the Future two specifically
enlarging food like this will apparently
be a huge deal for the Ant-Man family in
this third film though Van Dyne having
perfected the use of Bim technology and
applying it to things like food and
resources which is now winning hearths
and humanitarian Awards then this promo
shifts to focus on Kang
isn't what you think Kang the Conqueror
is terrifying and if there ever was a
maniac loose in the quantum realm it's
him playing Kang the Conqueror is such a
gift your reality
everything you're holding on to I know
how it is yeah they're really playing up
Colin Kane by his conqueror title more
and more perhaps fueling my theory that
Kang is behind every real world
historical conqueror based on major's
interview at Sundance check out
yesterday's video real proud of that one
and you probably noticed this BTS shot
of majors in costume we really get a
good look at the texture of King's suit
which now looks less decorative and more
weighty like a segmented glossy fabric
like it might all be a part of that same
neurokinetic armor that we've seen him
in other shots telekinetically shifting
Kang says here I've seen How It Ends
guess referring to the inevitable
destruction of the Multiverse or maybe
just the end of time that he remains
occupied he remains was building the
void as a kind of Utopia an unfinished
garden and maybe that Citadel Castle
used to be occupied by this King until
he was ousted and that conflict could
have what led to one of the statues
being broken now every time a new phone
comes out there's a lot of press about
the new camera chips memory and I don't
care the other thing my phone has to do
is not explode when I drop it because I
am the butterfingering this Butterfinger
of them all
oh no case device clear case series
takes care of that so here I got two
case options I'm gonna try out the snake
one I'm gonna pop my phone into it here
I'm in the blue dungeon I'm gonna drop
it from you know a head height here
and it is still working I think my phone
is even healthier now I don't know about
that how do you feel phone oh
it's picking personal tongue better than
ever now I mean it kind of makes sense
that case Defy is the world's most
popular Tech accessory brand just look
at this case I'm gonna pop into the
other one so you can see how clear it is
look at that Crystal Clear it's gonna
stay this way thanks to UV Defender
technology that's gonna keep it from
yellowing and look how Sleek this thing
is this tiny case can withstand drops
from over six feet which exceeds the
drop test standards the military uses
it's also mag save compatible so I can
still use my phone with my wireless
charger and you know if clear is not
your thing you can totally customize
your case and get the same protection
for your phone with some personalization
to boot
so to get started go to
casetify.com rockstars today to get 15
off on your order Majors then says this
is the beginning and he cannot be
contained yeah a pretty clear promise
that even if this variant of Kang is
killed in this movie The Kang Dynasty is
uncontainable and this movie will show
us how widespread the kings are and
intertwined with the lives of all
Avengers there's a quick shot of Hope
swooping down to rescue Scott from his
swarm of Schrodinger variants but a new
close-up of her hand grabbing his hand
if you go through this frame by frame
you can see other Scots reaching up too
which is pretty sad and pretty scary
like how does Hulk know which Scott is
the right one is it just the Scott whose
helmet is off kind of feel like this is
that Rick and Morty Jerry daycare moment
where they leave with the wrong Jerry
maybe we all just kind of go with it
from there forward actually the latest
season of Rick and Morty pretty much
confirmed that that mix-up actually
happened then this moment with Scott and
Cassie it's like we're camping we've
never been camping but we've always
talked about it I just noticed this
behind Scott is this glowing orange
bubble slowly moving to the right and
then in the second shot of Sky its
movement stutters or hiccups huh I'm
wondering if this could be a rival of
Med engine Taurus crew of Freedom
Fighters This just reminds me of the way
Glenn to the good witch floats via
bubble to Dorothy when Dorothy arrives
at odds to get her started on that
yellow brick road there might be a
connection there with the first trailer
and this promo sampling Elton John's
Goodbye Yellow Brick Road and there's
one more shot of Kang that is new I
gotta point it out because it is crazy
Kang steps forward from that golden
chair pod that we keep seeing him in
maybe his cockpit for a ship that he's
trying to reactivate and he emits these
fluid ribbons that he conducts like
whips snapping them into himself and
releasing an energy blast that
illuminates his eyes as he screams what
are these ribbons could be Kang
harnessing energy from the space around
him maybe connected to that ribbony
texture that Scott's giant man
Schrodinger variant disintegrates into
I'm still obsessed with this idea of
Kang pulling his life force remotely
from alternate timelines that feed into
him a more controlled antithesis to the
the unraveling we see Scott's variants
undergoing absorbing power from all
those branched timelines that he clipped
in the past setting up a cache of
temporal energy for him to dip into
whenever he needs it let me know what
you think is going on here hey and a
reminder to subscribe to the Deep dive
and follow me on Instagram and Twitter
at EA boss follow new rockstars And
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]